Iran's government says the fire that
broke out at Evan prison in Tehran on
Saturday was caused by fighting between
inmates overnight smoke was seen rising
from the facility and gunshots were
heard the Detention Center holds many
political prisoners officials say at
least nine people were injured
this fire was caused by a fight between
some prisoners in the sewing Workshop
the workshop was set up to create jobs
for the inmates
what is the latest you're hearing on
this now
while the fire started around 10 pm on
Saturday local time in in Tehran we have
seen that the blazes and the smoke
Rising above the infamous Evan Evin
prison and based on the the videos that
we have received we can see that is not
only hap it wasn't happening only in one
word but in different parts of the the
prison we could see that they are really
they're they're burning so official
statement was was that there was a clash
between the prisoners and some of the
prisoners set fire on on the the
warehouse or the sieven workshop in in
the in the prison and after that eight
people have been injured tehran's
Governor mohsin mansuri uh right
immediately after the the the the the
the the the the incident he went to the
prison and led the investigation he said
that those prisoners who set the fire
are those who have been charged based on
the financial frauds and theft and that
the political prisoners in the the
didn't get involved in the incidents so
but right after that we have seen that
all the roads around Evan prison have
been blocked by security forces and also
people gathered in the streets and there
was sporadic protests around the prison
so
despite all of these official statements
there are still questions that remain
unanswered one of that is that there is
no official explanation regarding the
explosions so far what has caused the
explosions and also another question is
that why would the prisoners risk their
lives with hope of No Escape and also
set the fire on the warehouse that the
places could quickly spread into their
Wars and claim their lives so every in
prison is one of the biggest prisons in
Iran and perhaps the most famous one
there are at least hundreds of the
political prisoners that are still kept
there particularly the the foreign
citizens that are charged based on spine
for for the foreign countries or
collecting sensitive information from
Iran and sending back to their countries
they are capped there including three
American citizens one of them is isiam
and also the the children of the former
president hashimura of sanjani is
there also there and today the family
released a statement said that
sanjana received a call from the
security forces and they asked him not
to come back to the prison because he
was on a third law for the weekend so we
do not know whether this is going to be
extended or not but based on this
statement we understand that the
situation in heaven prison is still not
fully brought under control and it is
still delicate through its disparate the
turbulent history there has been several
attempts to close it or to move the
prison out of tehrumba so far all of
that attempt failed yeah still a very
fluid situation there rasul Sardar
lifers in Tehran thank you